en este vídeo vamos a hablar del
crecimiento económico aquí debemos ser
cuidadosos porque la definición de
crecimiento económico va a depender del
contexto en el que usemos este término
para las personas incluidos los
economistas puede haber diferentes
concepciones en la vida cotidiana nos
referimos al crecimiento económico
cuando hablamos de la expansión de la
producción de una economía en el tiempo
entonces si el pib real aumenta la gente
podría considerar que hay crecimiento
económico pero en el contexto que vamos
a usar en esta ocasión es el que pueden
encontrar en las clases de introducción
a la economía o una clase de economía a
peu donde no vamos a referirnos
solamente al incremento del pib real en
el tiempo sino que vamos a ver el
incremento de la producción con pleno
empleo en el tiempo sin importar dónde
nos encontremos en el ciclo económico
debemos tener esto en mente durante este
vídeo si hablamos solamente del
incremento del pib real vamos a llamar a
esto expansión no necesariamente
crecimiento económico y cuando disminuye
el pib real le vamos a llamar
contracción cuando hablamos del
crecimiento económico no refería
al incremento de la producción con pleno
empleo esto puede ocurrir
independientemente de donde nos
encontremos en el ciclo económico vamos
a dibujar un diagrama para comprender
mejor esto aquí tenemos una gráfica del
pib real de una economía con respecto al
tiempo en anaranjado tenemos el
comportamiento del pib real que está
fluctuando alrededor de la producción
con pleno empleo que es la línea azul
vamos a elegir este momento en el tiempo
y le llamaremos t1 en este momento del
tiempo tenemos la producción con pleno
empleo que llamaremos y sub f1 vemos que
en este mismo instante de tiempo la
economía está por arriba de esta
producción con pleno empleo y tenemos
una brecha positiva de producción si
ahora vemos un momento adelante en el
tiempo llamado t 2 la producción con
pleno empleo se mantiene constante en
este rango podríamos pensar que no hay
incremento económico de t1 t2 aún cuando
el pib real muestra un crecimiento de
este punto a este otro punto una forma
de pensar en esto es que nos expandimos
mientras la curva tenga una pendiente
positiva pero
si la producción con pleno empleo no
cambia entonces no experimentamos
crecimiento económico los momentos en
los que experimentamos crecimiento
económico son aquellos donde cambia la
producción con pleno empleo de este
tiempo a este otro tiempo noten que esto
ocurre en teoría cuando hay una
contracción donde el pib real disminuye
pero si conociéramos la producción con
pleno empleo real y se comportará así
entonces tendríamos un crecimiento
económico a pesar de esta contracción
para apreciar esto veamos otros modelos
que hemos estudiado con anterioridad
veamos una curva de posibilidades de
producción las que hemos visto
típicamente tienen dos bienes o
servicios
aunque una economía real es mucho más
compleja y tendrá millones de bienes y
servicios pero algo así sería
tremendamente difícil de dibujar esto
nos muestra cuál es la producción con
pleno empleo durante un momento en el
tiempo y muestra su diferente nivel de
producción entre estos dos productos o
servicios
si estamos en una situación en donde
estamos por debajo de la curva de
posibilidades de producción es una
brecha de producción negativa
que con el tiempo pasemos de esta brecha
de producción negativa a la curva de
posibilidades de producción esto sería
una expansión de la economía pero de
acuerdo a la definición que estamos
manejando aquí y que es diferente a lo
que típicamente se maneja en la clase no
le llamaremos crecimiento económico a
esto el crecimiento económico ocurre
cuando movemos a la derecha la curva de
posibilidades de producción cuando se
incrementa la producción con pleno
empleo en este caso el crecimiento
económico se logra mediante nueva
tecnología o con más trabajadores o más
recursos o simplemente con mejores
instituciones es así como podemos mover
la curva de posibilidades de producción
este es un ejemplo de crecimiento
económico ésta puede ser la curva de
posibilidades de producción en el tiempo
de 3 que indicamos aquí y esta es la
curva de posibilidades de producción en
el tiempo t 4 que marcamos aquí en la
gráfica donde vemos que la producción
con pleno empleo se ha incrementado
también podemos ver la misma idea usando
la gráfica del modelo de demanda
agregada u oferta agregada cuando
estudiamos este modelo vimos que al
corto plazo quizás
debido a un choque de demanda o de
oferta nos podemos desplazar a la
derecha oa la izquierda de nuestra
producción con pleno empleo y que con el
tiempo volveríamos a la producción con
pleno empleo así pues mientras la curva
de posibilidades de producción no se
mueva hacia afuera o mientras que la
curva de oferta agregada a largo plazo
no cambie no habrá crecimiento económico
de acuerdo a la definición que
establecimos en este vídeo la analogía
de lo que vimos en el modelo de cpp es
que en el modelo de oferta y demanda
agregada suponiendo que ésta sea la
curva de oferta agregada a largo plazo
en t3 si la economía tiene más recursos
como más población o más recursos
naturales o mejor tecnología o mejores
instituciones podría aumentar el pleno
empleo en esta situación la curva de
oferta agregada a largo plazo se
desplaza a la derecha aquí está esta
curva en el tiempo t 4 aquí tenemos la
producción con pleno empleo en el tiempo
t 3 que llamaremos sub f 3 y acá tenemos
yes vf 4 en resumen no importa si nos
encontramos en expansión o contracción
del ciclo económico
el crecimiento económico se da cuando
cambia esta línea azul si vemos la cpp
esta curva se desplaza hacia afuera y si
vemos el modelo de oferta y demanda
agregada el crecimiento económico se da
cuando se desplaza a la derecha la curva
de oferta agregada a largo plazo y
cuáles son las cosas que pueden provocar
estos desplazamientos una es el capital
tradicionalmente el tener más fábricas
más recursos o más tierra puede ayudar
al crecimiento de la economía una
definición más moderna de capital
contempla el capital humano trabajadores
con mejor preparación o con más
habilidades pueden ayudar a esto otra
cosa es la tecnología si tenemos más
computadoras o sistemas automatizados
podremos producir más per cápita o por
persona otra cosa que importa son las
instituciones una burocracia más
eficiente puede hacer que las cosas
ocurran más rápido si el procedimiento
para lograr algo es muy tardado no puede
hacerse gran cosa y disminuye lo que se
puede producir si las instituciones son
eficientes se puede ampliar la
producción con pleno empleo
todas estas cosas pueden incrementar la
cpp o desplazar la curva de oferta
agregada a largo plazo o hacer que la
producción con pleno empleo se mueva
hacia arriba con el tiempo todo esto
indica crecimiento económico nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo